>> Tucker: PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BATTLE CREEK,
MICHIGAN.
LOUIE GOHMERT REPRESENTS THE
GREAT STATE OF TEXAS IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
THOUGH TONIGHT HE WAS IN
EFFECT ACCUSED OF
REPRESENTING ST. PETERSBURG
AND MOSCOW.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT TO
CLARIFY.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
YOU WERE DENOUNCED AS A TOOL
OF RUSSIA TONIGHT.
TELL US HOW THAT PLAYED OUT.
>> WELL, IT IS SUCH AN
OUTRAGE BECAUSE THE THING I
WAS POINTING OUT IS THAT IF
YOU WANT TO REALLY LOOK AT
THE FACTS, LOOK AT IN 2008,
RUSSIA INVADED GEORGIA.
AND BUSH RACKETED ADVERSELY
AND HE PUT SANCTIONS IN
PLACE.
AND THEN IN MARCH OF 2009,
OBAMA SENT CLINTON HAPPILY
FOR CLINTON OVER WITH A RED
PLASTIC RE-SET BUTTON.
THE MESSAGE TO PUTIN WAS
CLEAR.
BUSH OVERREACTED WHEN YOU
INVADED GEORGIA WITH ALL
THOSE SANCTIONS.
WE DON'T OVERREACT WHEN YOU
INVADE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, TO PUTIN,
IT WAS A GREEN LIGHT, GO
AHEAD AND INVADE CRIMEA,
BUT, OF COURSE, PUTIN WAS
SMART ENOUGH, HE WAITED
UNTIL OBAMA WON A SECOND
TERM BECAUSE HE HAD MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW RUSSIA
TO DO THINGS.
BUT, THEY HAVE BEEN THE
PAWNS OF THE RUSSIANS.
THEY -- YOU THINK THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT TRUMP